on est tous habitués à voir des
représentations de la structure de la
terre des dessins en coupe un peu comme
celui ci et à force de les voir dans ce
forment une image intuitive de ce qu'il
ya à l'intérieur de notre planète
vous savez des continents qui dérive en
flottant sur une espèce de océan de
magma en fusion
et ben non les continents ne flotte pas
du tout sûre du magma en fusion
en fait c'est même pas liquide en
dessous 1 aujourd'hui on va voir de quoi
est vraiment fait l'intérieur de la
terre et comment on fait pour le savoir
sans avoir besoin d'y aller
[Musique]
bon prenons donc cette fameuse
représentation classique dans cette
vision schématiser la terre serait
constitué de trois parties la croûte en
surface en dessous ce qu'on appelle le
manteau et au centre le noyau la
première précision il existe en fait
plusieurs représentations possible en
suivant qu'on s'intéresse plutôt aux
comportements physiques des différentes
parties ou à leur composition chimique
on va parler un peu des deux en surface
on a donc la croûte
alors c'est une couche solide qui nous
est familière puisque évidemment on vide
dessus alors question taille elle fait
entre 5 et 10 km d'épaisseur au niveau
des océans est plutôt une trentaine en
moyenne au niveau des continents à 30 km
c'est à la fois peu et beaucoup
c'est peu parce que c'est moins d'1 2
centièmes du rayon de la terre qui fait
environ six mille trois cent cinquante
kilomètres donc à l'échelle de la
planète ballack route c'est vraiment
juste une mince pellicule
si on l'a rapportée à la taille d'un
ballon de basket c'est comme si la
croûte ne faisait qu'un demi millimètre
d'épaisseur mais 30 km c'est quand même
beaucoup à notre échelle les mines les
plus profondes du monde celle de toto
nae dumping en afrique du sud ce sont
des mines d'or ne descendent au maximum
qu'à 4 kilomètres et le trou le plus
profond qu'on n'ait jamais creusé le
forage de colas près de mourmansk dans
le nord ouest de la russie n'a atteint
seulement que 12 km de profondeur et le
trou ne fait que 23 cm de diamètre donc
c'est un peu étroit pour descendre et
aller voir ce qui se passe en bas n'ont
de toute façon le projet a été abandonné
et l'entrée a même été scellé tout ça
pour dire que dans cet épisode je vais
disserter sur la structure interne de la
terre alors qu'en fait on a à peine
égratigné sa surface
bon passons maintenant à la question la
composition alors de quoi elle est faite
cette croûte
bah ça on voit bien autour de nous un la
croûte c'est du caillou enfin sauf que
ce qu'on appelle vulgairement un caillou
c'est quand même un truc assez compliqué
en fait
du point de vue de la composition
chimique les éléments qu'on retrouve
dans la croûte terrestre
ce sont principalement de l'oxygène du
silicium de l'aluminium du fer du
calcium du sodium du potassium du
magnésium et puis quelques autres
évidemment ces éléments il se balade pas
isolé en fait ils s'associent pour
former des minéraux par exemple silicium
et l'oxygène se combinent pour former du
quartz sio2 mais aussi décomposé plus
complexe faisant intervenir d'autres
éléments
on les appelle collectivement les
silicates on leur donne des petits noms
suivants leur composition et leur
structure
en fait il ya tellement de possibilités
qu on les regroupe en famille il ya par
exemple la famille des faits le spath
bien celle d'amy cas ces minéraux on les
retrouve parfois à l'état isolé
il forme alors de jolis cristaux avec
des belles formes géométriques plutôt
sympathique mais il faut savoir que la
plupart du temps ils sont de toutes
petites tailles et il rentre dans la
composition des roches qui sont en fait
un assemblage de plusieurs minéraux
par exemple le granit c'est pas un
minéral pur c'est en fait une roche
composé de quartz de feldspath et demie
qu'a et dont l'aspect peut varier
suivant la taille et la couleur des
cristaux qui le composent
il existe en fait plein de types de
roches qui forment la croûte terrestre
et qui varient suivant l'endroit où on
se trouve avec en particulier des
différences entre la croûte continentale
et la croûte océanique mais aussi des
différences suivant qu'on se trouve en
surface ou en profondeur par exemple
autour de nous en surface on retrouve
souvent des roches sédimentaires comme
les calcaires mais en fait en quantité
il représente moins de 10% du volume
total de la croûte terrestre
vous voyez donc que la question la
composition de la croûte terrestre est
en fait assez compliqué et surtout
dépend de si on décide de regarder au
niveau des roches des minéraux ou bien
simplement des éléments chimiques
bien passons maintenant à ce qu'il ya
sous la croûte terrestre cette grande
région qu'on appelle le manteau entre ce
qu'on nous explique sur la dérive des
continents et le fait qu'au niveau des
volcans en voie de la lawe s'échapper
ben on a bien envie de penser que le
manteau effet de roches en fusion
et ben non contrairement à ce qu'on a
envie de s'imaginer le manteau n'est pas
liquide
il est fait de roche qui sont bien
solides alors pourquoi on s'imagine ça
m'est déjà peut-être à cause du fait que
effectivement dans le manteau y fait
chaud il fait très chaud
voyez ici un graphique qui représente la
température moyenne de la terre en
fonction de la profondeur dans la mine
de tortona à 4 km il fait déjà 60 degrés
et dans le manteau la température se
baladent allègrement entre 1000 et 3000
degrés or on sait qu'en laboratoire bas
la plupart des roches fondent entre 800
et 1300 degrés donc logiquement on
s'attendrait à ce que dans le manteau
avec la température qui fait les roches
soit tout fondu oui mais non il ya un
autre truc à prendre en compte c'est la
pression de même que la température
grimpe quand on s'enfonce sous terre est
bien la pression augmente également et
elle augmente même beaucoup dans le
manteau on dépasse un million de fois la
pression atmosphérique
or généralement plus la pression est
importante plus il est difficile de
faire fondre un solide parce qu'en fait
sa température de fusion augmente avec
la pression sur ce graphique vous voyez
de représentation de ce qu'on pensait
être la courbe de fusion de la bridge
mann heat c'est un silicate de magnésium
et de fer qui est le composé principal
du manteau terrestre et quand la
pression augmente mais on voit que son
point de fusion augmente aussi très
rapidement à prenons un exemple
à 1000 km de profondeur la pression et
de 400000 barre donc le point de fusion
et autour de 3000 degrés mais à cette
profondeur il ne fait que 2000 degrés
donc pas assez chaud pour que la roche
soit fondu si on s'enfonce encore un peu
à 2000 km de profondeur on est autour de
800 mille barre et là le point de fusion
dépasse les quatre mille degrés mais il
fait à peine de 1500 degrés donc la
roche est toujours solide et en fait ou
qu'on se place dans l'épaisseur du
manteau d à la pression est toujours tel
que le point de fusion est bien
supérieure à la température qui règne
est donc dans le manteau les roches sont
solides pas liquide
évidemment ces chiffres de température
et de pression dans le manteau ce sont
des moyennes et peut toujours exister
des régions par exemple juste sous la
croûte terrestre où il règne une
pression modérée mais si des roches
suffisamment chaude arrive à remonter et
bien elles peuvent fondre et c'est ça
qui forment les chambres magmatiques qui
alimente les volcans mais contrairement
à l'image intuitive ses chambres ne sont
pas au milieu du manteau elles sont
généralement situées à faible profondeur
quelques kilomètres où quelques dizaines
de kilomètres sous la surface
continuons maintenant notre descente à
environ 3000 km de profondeur on arrive
dans une zone complètement différente
le noyau tout d'abord le noyau n'est pas
fait de roche mais des éléments plus
lourds ou plutôt plus dense en majorité
du fer et un peu de nickel ah oui le
faire c'est dans st déjà à pression
atmosphérique sa densité est de 8 alors
que c'est environ trois pour la plupart
des cailloux dans la vie de tous les
jours on a du mal à réaliser la densité
de ces métaux jusqu'au jour où on se
retrouve à devoir porter un bloc d'acier
de la taille d'une brique de lait et ben
il pèse huit kilos
bref le fer et le nickel sont lourds et
donc à la formation de la terre et bien
ils ont coulé vers le centre pour former
le noyau mais du coup même question le
noyau c'est solide où ces liquides et
bien on peut faire le même raisonnement
tout à l'heure voici la courbe de fusion
du fer en fonction de la pression voyez
déjà que les températures de fusion sont
beaucoup plus basses que pour les
constituants du manteau un dessus je
peut superposer les différentes
conditions de température et de pression
qu'on trouve au fur à mesure que l'on
s'enfonce dans l'ohio
vous voyez que sur la partie externe du
noyau la moins profonde
la température est supérieure au point
de fusion du fer donc à cet endroit est
bien le faire et bien liquide mais plus
on s'enfonce plus les coupes se
rapproche et aux alentours de 5000 km de
profondeur
elles se croisent c'est à dire qu'au
delà de cette profondeur la pression est
telle que le point de fusion dû faire
des passes la température qui règne est
donc le faire et
l'idh est ce petit raisonnement nous
montre que le noyau est en fait
constituée de deux parties
le noyau externe dans lequel le faire et
liquides et le noyau interne dans lequel
la pression est suffisante pour le
maintenir solide et c'est cette région
qu'on appelle la graine dans le cadre du
noyau externe il ya donc pas de méprise
1 on a bien du vrai liquide du métal en
fusion
alors pour être complet il faut quand
même dire qu'il ya eu un débat chez les
spécialistes pour savoir quelle était la
viscosité du fer liquide dans ces
conditions un peu extrême est la réponse
qui fait consensus c'est que le noyau
externe aurait une viscosité qui serait
comprise en gros entre celle de l'eau et
celle de l'huile donc c'est vraiment un
vrai liquide au sens de l'image
intuitive qu'on s'en fait si on y allait
en toi et nager dedans enfin à quatre
mille degrés ce métal en fusion qui
forment le noyau externe est même
tellement liquide qu'ils agitaient de
courant un peu comme dans l'océan mais
qui ont pour origine le mouvement de
rotation de la terre sur elle-même et à
cause d'un phénomène appelé effet dynamo
ce sont ces mouvements de fer en fusion
qui donne naissance au champ magnétique
terrestre
vous avez subi corientes les boussoles
d'ailleurs le fait que le champ
magnétique trouve son origine dans ces
courants de métal a plusieurs
conséquences
tout d'abord comme ces courants sont
liées à la rotation de la terre bas ça
explique que les pôles magnétiques se
situe à peu près au même endroit que les
pôles géographiques sauf que la
proximité est pas parfaite
actuellement le nord magnétique est
plutôt situé au niveau du groenland et
d'ailleurs on sait que les pôles
magnétiques se déplacent ils peuvent
même bougé d'une dizaine de kilomètres
d'une année sur l'autre
et pire un de temps en temps enfin
l'échelle de quelques millions d'années
quand même les pôles peuvent s'inverser
ça c'est quelque chose qu'on sait qu'on
a pu reconstituer grâce à l'orientation
de roches qui ont des propriétés
magnétiques ces inversions se produisent
de manière apparemment aléatoire et la
dernière a eu lieu il ya 780 mille ans
et bah du coup on sait pas quand aura
lieu la prochaine
alors pas de panique quand même harry
semble que quand le champs magnétiques
s'inversent s'apprennent quand même
quelques centaines ou quelques milliers
d'années
mais bon il ya certains scientifiques
qui pense que ça pourrait aller plus
vite et si jamais ça se produisait il y
aura quand même deux trois appareils
adaptés 1
[Musique]
revenons maintenant à la structure de la
terre on l'a dit si le noyau externe est
un vrai liquide le manteau lui est bien
solide
mais du coup comment on explique cette
idée de dérive des continents et cette
image un peu intuitive qu'on a de croûte
terrestre qui flottent et bien même s'il
est solide le manteau peut se déformer
en quelque sorte un peu comme un liquide
mais un liquide incroyablement visqueux
un truc du genre
un milliard de milliards de fois plus
visqueux que du beurre de cacahuète et
du coup les déformations du manteau sont
extrêmement lentes 1 à l'interface avec
la croûte terrestre c'est environ deux
centimètres par an si on regarde les
choses dans leur globalité le manteau
est animé d'un mouvement qu'on appelle
de convection et qu'on peut rapprocher
de certains mouvements de l'air ou de
l'océan les roches en surface sont plus
froides donc plus dense et plonge dans
le manteau et en contrepartie les roches
du manteau qui sont plus chaudes s'élève
et l'ensemble créé un mouvement de
circulation
alors là je le décris comme si ça se
passait à cette vitesse là mais il faut
savoir que le cycle complet prend plutôt
plusieurs dizaines de millions d'années
alors depuis le début de la vidéo je
vous raconte plein de trucs sur la
structure interne de la terre sur ce qui
se passe à 3000 km de profondeur
mais maintenant je vous ai dit qu'on
avait jamais creuser plus profond que 12
km alors comment on fait pour savoir
tout ça est le premier indice pour
réaliser que la terre d'avoir une
structure particulière c'est de regarder
simplement sa densité
on connaît son rayon donc son volume et
on connaît sa masse donc on peut
calculer la densité moyenne de la terre
et on trouve environ 5,5 g par
centimètre cube à cette valeur est plus
élevé que la densité n'importe quel rush
qui est généralement autour de 3 déjà ça
nous montre que la terre peut pas être
faite juste de cailloux 1 et la
différence on vient le voir baisser à
cause du noyau métallique qui est
beaucoup plus dense en fait à cause de
la pression sa densité et même autour de
11 ou 12 on peut d'ailleurs faire le
même raisonnement pour la lune un
calculer sa densité et conclure qu'elle
possède elle aussi un noyau métallique
mais qui doit être beaucoup plus petit 1
seulement un cinquième de son rayon
autre indice ce sont les météorites et
notamment celle qu'on appelle les
chondrites elles proviennent de petits
astéroïdes qui sont formés au moment de
la naissance du système solaire et donc
de la terre et les chondrites sont des
météorites qui ne sont pas différencier
c'est à dire qu'elles n'ont pas une
structure interne avec un coeur
métallique 1 comme la terre mais leur
composition globale nous renseigne sur
la matière de base qui a servi à cette
époque à la formation des planètes
mais surtout ce qui a révolutionné
l'étude et la compréhension de la
structure interne de la terre
c'est une invention qui étaient déjà
connus des chinois depuis plusieurs
siècle mais qui a pris son essor qu'au
19e le sismographe un sismographe c'est
un appareil qui permet d'enregistrer les
mouvements du sol provoqués par les
tremblements de terre les séismes on a
maintenant des sismographes un peu
partout sur la planète et ils sont
suffisamment précis pour capter les
vibrations à des distances de plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres de l'épicentre du
séisme
mais comment ça nous renseigne sur la
structure interne de la planète tout
d'abord il faut savoir que quand la
terre tremble elle émet des vibrations
dans toutes les directions
mais il existe deux types de vibrations
du sol en profondeur les ondes paix et
les ondes
est ce le meilleur moyen de comprendre
la différence c'est de les visualiser
avec un ressort une amp p c'est ce qu'on
appelle une onde de pression et c'est ça
la roche est comprimé à un endroit et
cette compression se propage saison de
pression existe dans les roches mais
aussi dans l'air c'est comme ça que le
son se propage une onde est ce par
contre c'est ce qu'on appelle une onde
de cisaillement et c'est ça ça n'est pas
le même mécanisme de transmission de
l'énergie et dans les roches d'ailleurs
leur propagation est plus lente que
celle des ondes paix mais surtout une
grande différence entre les ondes paix
et les ondes s
c'est que les ondes p les ondes de
pression se propage dans les solides
dans les liquides ou dans les gaz alors
que les ondes s les ondes de
cisaillement ne se propage que dans les
solides quand un séisme se produit un
endroit donné
il ya émission d'onde un peu dans toutes
les directions et qui peuvent être
détectés en d'autres points du globe par
les sismographes mais les ondes s ne
peuvent se propager que si elles n'ont
que du solide à traverser et elles sont
stoppés en quelque sorte par le liquide
du noyau externe et cela créé toute une
zone à l'opposé de l'épicentre dans
laquelle on ne détectera pas dans s on
appelle cette région la zone d'ombré
alors en réalité le schéma des
trajectoires et pas si simple c'est un
petit peu plus compliqué que ça il faut
savoir que la vitesse des ondes
sismiques dépend du milieu dans lequel
elle se propage
c'est comme la lumière rouge sont
d'ailleurs et les ondes sismiques voyage
plus vite dans les milieux plus denses
et donc plus elles sont profondes plus
elles vont vite en réalité la
trajectoire des ondes est donc plutôt la
suivante en fait elle se courbe sous
l'effet des variations densité et du
coup on obtient une zone d'ombré des
ondes s dont la taille nous renseignent
à la fois sur la densité des différentes
couches et sur l'étendue du noyau
liquide qui les stops
alors pour les npc plus subtile elles
peuvent se propager dans les liquides
donc elles n'ont pas être arrêtée par le
noyau externe
mais quand elle arrive dans cette zone
où la densité change brutalement et bien
elles vont être déviés c'est d'ailleurs
un analogue à ce qui se passe pour des
ondes lumineuses
quand la lumière change de milieux
qu'elle passe de l'air à l'eau ou de
l'air au vert ou l' inverse avec ce
produit des phénomènes de déviation des
rayons qu'on appelle la réfraction et
bien c'est pareil pour les ondes
sismiques et notamment pour les ondes p
voilà ce qui se passe comme pour les
ondes s certaines vont être déviés vers
la surface sans avoir à traverser le
noyau tandis que d'autres vont entrer
dans le royaume et subir une réfraction
et cela créera aussi une zone d'ombré
pour les ondes paix mais qui sera situé
différemment de celle des ondes s avec
une forme un peu en nano comme ça et
donc chaque fois qu'un séisme se produit
on peut apprendre une foule de choses
sur la structure interne de la terre
en analysant les ondes ps qui sont
captés par les différents sismographe
située à la surface de la planète et
c'est parfois assez subtil par exemple
je vous ai parlé de la graine tout à
l'heure vous savez la partie solide du
noyau métallique et ben il a fallu
attendre 1936 et des observations
sismique fait par inge lehman pour
découvrir qu'il y avait quelque chose de
nouveau à cet endroit là et des mesures
plus précises dans les années 70 pour
confirmer qu'il s'agissait bien d'une
graine solide donc finalement ça fait
pas si longtemps que ça qu'on connaît
bien la structure interne de la terre
est d'ailleurs pour compléter ces
observations sismique il faut savoir
qu'il a fallu aussi pas mal d'expérience
qui ont été faites plutôt en laboratoire
sur les différents matériaux les roches
et les métaux qui composent la structure
par exemple il a fallu réalisés en
laboratoire des mesures de densité et de
fusion sous très haute pression et sous
très haute température et aussi des
simulations numériques ont permis de
comprendre comment la matière s'agencer
dans des conditions aussi extrêmes et
d'ailleurs je trouve ça assez
remarquable de voir que si on arrive à
en savoir autant sur la structure de la
terre c'est à la fois par la combinaison
d'observation sismique à l'échelle de la
planète et d'expériences extrêmes en
laboratoire sur des échantillons de
minuscules c'est un bel exemple de
sciences ou le très grand rejoint le
très petit merci d'avoir suivi la vidéo
si elle vous a plu n'hésitez pas à la
partager pour faire connaître à tout le
monde le fait que non
on n'est pas liquide vous pouvez aussi
mettre des pneus la cloche tout ça pour
les actus de la chaîne ça se passe sur
facebook et sur twitter et ceux qui le
souhaitent peuvent nous soutenir sur
tipi merci à bientôt
[Musique]